the way to understand God's relationship
to history is through a concept of
Providence Christianity is especially uh
an historical understanding of God
because God takes on human flesh in the
Incarnation then lives for 33 years and
then is crucified and then on the third
day rises again from the dead and then
he's on Earth for 40 days and then he
ascends up into heaven and sends the
Holy Spirit to his church which is the
visible expression of God's kingdom here
on Earth so I'm with you in God's role
in history but the the error you've made
is that you uh have forced God to be
subject to time before God made time no
I'm saying but again this is assuming
that he did any of those things but I'm
saying how do you know that he couldn't
have made himself subject to that time
how do we know that it's without how do
we know that it's outside of the
possibility of a God to both create time
and create himself in the time how do we
know that one how do we know that one
has to proceede another for operating on
the framework of God because the creator
has to proceede the created